[موسيقى]
بعد المهرجان صله تاسست عدد من المهرجان
هذا اللي قلته واغلبها وهذا اختيار جيد
اغلبها اخذت او انبنى على شخصيه المدينه
نفسها حلو في مدينه الصويره مثلا اختارت
موسيقى كناوه وهي موسيقى افريقيه نعم فاس
اختارت
ان تعمل مهرجان الموسيقى الروحيه سفينه
والصوفيه
وهذا ايضا لانه مرتبط بشخصيه المدينه فاس
اكادير مدينه جديده
وحديثه موسيقى
متنوعه
وفيه شخصيه امازيغيه
مراكش لها
صارت عالميه
بسبب السياحه والسبب الوجهه السياحيه
الاولى في المغرب تاريخيا فيها مهرجان
دولي للسينما
هو اكبر مهرجان الدولي في المغرب
في تطوان وهي احدى المدن المتوسطيه
الاساسيه على المتوسط فيها مهرجان سينما
المتوسطيه في طنجه وهي مدينه حديثه ومشرفه
هيدا ايضا على في مهرجان الفيلم القصير
المتوسطي وشيء مهم ايضا في هذا في هذه
الشبكه من المهرجانات انها ارتبطت بالعمل
الاهلي
ونبقى هنا في اصيله مع الوزير والشاعر
والروائي محمد الاشعري لمتابعه الجوله معه
في تجربته وحياته اما هذه الاطلاله على
مهرجانات المدن المغربيه فكانت نتيجه دواء
جدنا في اصيله وفي موسمها الذي اشرف على
نصف قرن تقريبا منذ بدايه تاسيسه والذي
شكل عدوى جميله في العديد من المدن
المغربيه وبالطبع للوزير الاشعري دور في
كل ذلك
وهذه المدن
الجميله
بحاجه لمن يحبها لكي تصبح جميله يعني كل
امكنه تحتاج لمن يحبها لتصبح اكثر جمالا
ليس هذه ميزه مغربيه يعني انا نتيجه
تجوالي في بعض المدن بحس في حب من اهل
البلاد ومن القيمين على هذه البلاد في جعل
جميل وانيقه ومرحب
ومطمئنه لزائرها ولاهلها المدن في المغرب
بسرعه عامه هي الذخيره الاساسيه
للحضاره المغربيه
وللاستقرار المغربي تعرف نحن من الممكن ان
تزور عددا كبيرا من المدن في المغرب وتدرك
من اول وهله
انها لا تختلف كثيرا عن العواصم او عن
العاصمه لان لها نفس المؤهلات لها نفس
بنايه التحتيها لها نفس متوفر فيها نفس
الخدمات
وهذا الامر يذكرني بجولات كنت قمت بها في
بعض بلدان المشرق العربي
وكانت الملاحظه الاساسيه التي اخرج بها هو
ان البلاد كبيره لكن فيها مدينه واحده
كبيره او مدينتين كبيرتين يعني والباقي
عباره عن قرى متمدنه بينما المغرب فيها
اولا عواصم امبراطوريه لان الملكيه وراءها
قرون
والامبراطوريه المغربيه كانت ممتده عبر
مساحات جغرافيه شاسعه وفي كل مره كانت بعض
المدن
تكون هي العاصمه فاس كانت عاصمه مراكش
كانت عاصمه مكناس كانت عاصمه قصدي انه
المغرب شمالا وجنوبا يتوفر على بؤر حضريه
قويه
مطمئنه وفيها تنتج كثير من الاشياء التي
تساهم في تشكيل الهويه المغربيه وفي هذه
المدن انصهرت التيارات الاندلسيه
والتيارات الامازيغيه
وتيارات اخرى
المدن عباره عن عن مظاهر حقيقيه لادماج
المكونات المختلفه للهويه المغربيه التي
تصنع هذا الجمال وربما هي كمان البلاد
تحظى تحظى غالبا
بقامات يعني مثقفه
ومحبي
وليس مديحا فيك يعني يعني انت وقت اللي
اتيت الى وزاره الثقافه قبل حوالي 20 سنه
تقريبا في سنه 98 يعني اكثر من 20 سنه نعم
يعني لمساتك لم تزل قائمه حتى الان
كتير مشاريع مشاريع التنمويه وثقافيه
بمعظم المدن المغربيه وهذا اساس يعني اذا
لم يكن المناضل والسياسي مثقفا اظن لا
يستطيع ان يعمل اضافي حتى لو احتل الموقع
مهما كان عظيما هذه المنطقه في مجال
الثقافه اظن ان الاهم هو ان يكون المسؤول
على قدر من الاهتمام بالانتاج الفكري
والفني لبلده وان لا يكون مجرد مدبر اداري
او مدبر مالي مثلا في فرنسا في عهد تولى
حقيبه وزاره الثقافه
معروف انه هو جامعي اقرب للتاريخ لكن هو
في نفس الوقت كان ايضا مسؤول في مدينه
افينيو عن مهرجان افينيو السينما المسرح
وكان من هذا المنطلق كان اهتمامه بالمجال
الثقافي اهتمام مستهلك ذكي يعرف
مختلف الانتاجات الفنيه
والادبيه في فرنسا ويتابعها عن قرب لذلك
نجح فيه في
مهمته الى بعض الحدود هاد الجانب اظن
ضروري في مسؤوليه في السمات الذي يحتل هذا
الموقع نعم بس انت تعرف ايضا انه اليوم
الثقافه ليست فقط
الانتاج الفني والادبي ولكن هي ايضا
صناعات
لتدبيرها يجب التوفر على طاقات مهمه وهناك
ما يسمى في الغرب اليوم بالاقتصاد الثقافي
نتحول الى هذا المسار لابد من اطر تسير
الثقافه بطريقه اقتصاديه وليس فقط
المهرجانات اللي في المغرب نوع من
الاستثمار
ومستورات
والحفاظ على التراث وتقديمه كمنتج سياحي
هذا مساهمه كبيره في تنميه المجتمعات نعم
تاخذنا الامكنه احيانا الى هامش يصبح متنا
ولان الحب والجمال ينقذ العالم قد تكون
الاشاره الى تجلياته تمنح بعض الطمانينه
كنت التقيت بمحمد الاشعري يوم كان وزيرا
للثقافه اي قبل حوالي 22 عاما امور كثيره
تغيرت بين ذاك الامس واليوم اما الذي بقي
من الامس كما يقول محمد الاشعري هو نوع من
التوتر الموجود في كل تفاوض صعب بحد ذاته
هذا التوتر يحفز على معرفه ما يسببه
نحن نعيش باستمرار
في تفاوضات صعبه تفاوض معدات تفاوض مع
اللغه كنا نتكلم عن ذلك
تفاوض على الحياه كيف
كيف نعيشها وكيف نختمها
وتفاوض في الحياه المشتركه ما يدهشني
احيانا اليوم ارى في الوضع الراهن وفي
الحياه الاجيال الحديثه ضغوط تفاوضات لا
تنتهي
لانه
مجتمعاتنا خضعت لنوع من اعاده التقليديه
دائما اعطي مثلا عن ذلك بكون
جيلي مثلا تزوج في اطار
علاقات
داخل الجامعه وبعد ذلك كانت هذه الزجاجات
بسيطه ولم
لم تلجا الى الاساليب التقليديه على
الاطلاق هلا الجيل نعم ابناء جيلي
يدعونني اليوم في حفلات تزويج ابنائهم على
طريقه القرن التاسع عشر يعني شيء لا يصدق
كيف نعود الى احياء التقليديه من جديد
ولذلك فالشباب مضطرون اليوم للتفاوض على
كل شيء يوميا ونحن معهم ايضا ولو اننا اقل
شبابا فاننا نفاوض المجتمع على ما يسمح به
وما لا يسمح به نفاوض الحاكمين على ما
يسمحون به وما لا يسمحون به نفاوض انفسنا
على العالم نسمح به لانفسنا وما نسمح به
لانفسنا وهذا ما يعبر بشكل جيد على اننا
بالرغم من التقدم المادي الذي نعيشه فان
على مستوى
السلوكات والقيم لا نتقدم كثيرا
هناك تقدم ولكن ليس هناك تغيير ليست مجرد
كلمه لها محتوى هو الاعمال العقل والحريات
الفرديه هو الاختيار الحر هذا هذا هو
التقدم التقدم بني على الانجازات العلميه
والتكنولوجيه وعلى الانجازات في المجال
القيمي
[موسيقى]
البحر وضعني هنا حيث انا في القناعات
الصغيره في الخوف من الماء في نصف ابتسامه
تعبر المحيط في الشراع الذي اخذته العاصفه
كلما مشيت معه احلم انني اقود حصانا مرنا
الى المراعي احس لهذه
قريبا يكاد يلفحه كتفيه واسمع نبضه يصفف
امواجا مالحه كانه يضعها لالي ادمع على
وجنه الارض ثم فجاه يصبح الحصان ابديه
بيضاء
تتبعني انا العابر المخيم في روح عابره
كما يقال دائما هناك
الكثير ممن يكتبون الشعر ولكن الشعر قليل
هذه السمه غالبه منذ
بدايه التاريخ نعم انت حتى الان 15 ديوان
اذا بدنا نسال عن يعني هو سؤال شوي تقليدي
عن روافد القصيده عند محمد الاشعري
روافدها كيف يتشكلت علاقتها بالمكان
علاقتها باللغه علاقتها بالوجدان علاقتها
بالتامل
بالحنين يعني هناك الكثير من الروافد هي
التي
لها علاقه بكل ذلك نعم
اظن انه هناك رافد اساسي
قليلا ما نتحدث عنه رافض القراءه يعني لا
يمكن
للشاعر ان يطور ادواته
التعبيريه والشعريه بدون ان يكون قارئا
جيدا للشعر وللتجارب الاساسيه في الشعر
العالمي هذا يعني انا متيقن انه عنصر
اساسي في بناء الهويه الشعريه لكل شاعر
وبعد ذلك بالطبع هناك اختيارات نمر منها
انا في بدايه تجربتي كنت
كباقي شعراء جيلي
منتبها للقضايا الكبرى التي تؤرق بال
الشعب المغربي انذاك وهي قضايا متعلقه
بالحريه ومقاومه الاستبداد بالسعي الى الى
الحصول على حقوق ديمقراطيه في البلد وهذا
بالطبع كان
حاسوبيه الشعر في القصيده هذا ايوه هذا
وكان يوحي اليه بان الشعر ممكن ان يحقق
المعجزات في هذا الاطار
لكن كما تعرف يعني في في كل تجارب الشعريه
تحدث التحولات والتحول الاساسي الذي حصل
في المغرب هو ان عددا كبيرا من شعراء
السبعينات الذي كانت لهجتهم
السياسيه اقوى من لهجتهم الشعريه في
قصادهم الاولى
توجهوا بعد ذلك بفعل الروافض المتعدده
التي ذكرت بفعل قراءتهم للتجارب الشعريه
العالميه وبفضل ايضا انتباههم لبعض
الاشياء الاساسيه في الحياه وليس فقط في
الشعر ان الطفوله الامكنه
العلاقات الانسانيه
الخيبات الخسارات
الفجائع التي نمر منها
الافراح
التفاصيل اليوميه التي نعيشها
والتي نعتقد ربما خطا انها ليست سوى
تفاصيل ولكن عندما تاخذ الحياه في مجملها
فانها مشكله من هذه التفاصيل طالما فتحت
هذا الباب الانتباه لعناصر الحياه اليوميه
اللي عم نعيش الان يعني هناك مفردات جديده
دخلت يعني
كيف يعني اللغه الشعريه كيف تتعامل مع هذه
الحدثات يعني الجديده التي دخلت علينا
الشعر كما تعرف يعني ليس وعاء لتسجيل
المستجدات اللغويه اللفظيه صح يعني مهمه
القواميس الشعر يلتقيت
ليس فقط المفردات ولكن يلتقط ايضا المشاعر
ويلتقط المظاهر الاخرى للغه التهكم
السخريه التامل
وهذه هي التي تجعل الشعر قادرا على خلق
لغه جديده
[موسيقى]
المغامره الشعريه والتجريب والانطلاق من
الاشياء غير المنتظره غير المتوقعه هو هذا
الذي يدفع الشعر الى
ارتياد افاق جديده والى خلق لغه جديده
وعلى فكره
التطور التطور اللغات مرتبط الى حد كبير
بتطور تجارب الشعريه في هذه اللغات كثيرا
سمعت بعض السياسيين مثلا في بلادنا يقولون
نحن لحاجه لنا بالشعر وبالروايه وبالقصه
نحن في حاجه الى المهندسين والى تقنيين
والى الاطباء وهذه الاشياء لسنا في حاجه
اليها فان اعدام الادب والشعر في مجتمع هو
اعدام للغه يعني غريب هذا بعض السياسيين
اظن
لا اريد ان اوصف احدا ولكن نحن نسجل حوار
في هذا القصر الان هذا كله قصائد الاصل
الخطوط الانحناءات الزخرفه
وفي نفس الوقت لا يدركون شيئا اساسيا كيف
يمكن ان نسمح في بلداننا بتكوين اجيال من
المتعلمين والجامعيين والمهندسين دون ان
نفرض في هذه المناهج كلها
نظاما تربويا
يجعل الطلبه يقراون الادب والفلسفه في كل
انواع واسلاك التعليم هناك دراسه مهمه
كتير حول العمليات الارهابيه والذين قاموا
بها وهيئوا اليها هم كلهم معظم مختصين
بالكمبيوتر بالعالم الرقمي
وبالهندسه وبالاشياء ليس لها علاقه
بالعلوم الانسانيه ولا واحد طري فلس في او
درس علم اجتماع او درس ادب او شيء اضافه
للنصوص التراثيه التي يعني يختارون منها
ما
يسالفهم على التفجير وانت لو سالتها هؤلاء
هل قراوا في حياتهم
ديوان شعريا او روايه فانهم
سيجيبون طبعا بلا لذلك لابد من يعني من
التعويل والانتباه على تطعيم المناهج مش
تطعيمها على جعل المناهج متوازنه متوازنه
ثانيا متوازنه ما الفائده من تكوين مهندس
وطبيب اذا كان هذا المهندس الطبيب لا لا
توجد بداخله ايه بذور من الوجدان المشترك
وهو الخيال المشترك
للاسف للاسف كنا عم نتحدث عنه انه
التحولات في العالم طبعا يعني تفرض لغه
شاعريه موازيه ولكن ايضا مثل ما ذكرت
الذهاب الى لغات اخرى
الى اللغه الاخرى التي يكتب فيها الشعر
غير العربي ايضا تجعل الكاتب او الشاعر
ينتبه الى موضوعات او الى لغه اخرى يعني
قمت بمقاربه بينك يعني بين النص الشعري
العربي بشكل عام عم بحكي وبين النص الذي
يكتب بلغات اخرى اللي هو بالاسبانيه او
بالفرنسيه او الانجليزيه في ميزان في
ميزان وضعته لتشوف هناك بعض
الملاحظات في نظري مهمه في الاونه الاخيره
صدر كتاب في الاندلس يجمع بين شعراء
مغاربه وشعراء اندلسيين
المغربي هناك التجارب الاسبانيه مترجمه
الى العربيه والتجارب المغربيه مترجمه الى
الاسبانيه
من يقرا القصائد سيلاحظ
بسهوله ان هناك التقاء في عدد من المواضيع
ولكن هناك
تباين كبير في اساليب التعبير وفي الجمله
الشعريه وفي الرؤيه الشرعيه كذلك جميل
واطلاعي على هذا النوع من
يجعلني افكر بان الشعر يجب ان لا يعيش في
طاعه مغلقه وفي ولا تخنقه لغته يجب ان
يتغذى من لغات اخرى ومن ترجمات ومن لان
هذا هو الذي يمكن ان يؤسس لحوار بين
شعريات مختلفه كثير من اللغات مثلا طورت
التعبيرات مرتبطه
بقضايا معينه او بمواضيع معينه هناك لقاء
مثلا مستمر بين الفلسفه والشعر في الشعر
الالماني هناك لقاء عميق بين الطبيعه
والشعر في الشعر الياباني هناك
علاقه قويه مع البحر
والمجهول البحر في الشعر البرتغالي لدينا
لدينا ايضا شيء من هذا ولكن
ربما نحن
ما يميزنا هو الارتباط
بالتعبير البلاغي اكثر من من هذه
الاهتمامات الاخرى
ولذلك نحتاج الى الخروج من من هذا النفق
البلاغي نحتاج الى الخروج منه اللغه
العربيه لها قدرات خارقه على تكيف وعلى
وعلى التحول في اشتقاقات ولكن الشعر ليس
مساله لغويه فحسف تماما ولهذا يجب ان نخرج
كذلك من من
غول اللغه نحن نكتب بلغه لها هيمنه
عليها ويجب ان نتحرم فيها شيء من القدسيه
يعني
ويبقى الكثير الذي يقال مع الوزير والشاعر
والروائي محمد الاشعري في السياسه وفي
الانجاز الابداعي وفي الجوائز العربيه
التي نال منها نصيبا جيدا ويستحق اكثر
وحين سالته عن الكتابه والشك بما نكتب
اجاب والله
انا دائما عندي هذا
ولكن لا اعتبره يعني علامه على
شيء جيد ولا على شيء سيء يعني هو مرتبط
بشخصيه ان هكذا لا اطمئن كثيرا لما تنجزه
وفي شيء انا لا ارجع ابدا الى نصوص
لاقراها مره اخرى
نصوص التي صدرت حتى الان مستحيل ان ارجع
الى نص لاقراه او لاقراه بعد صفحته لدي
دائما شعور بالخجل مما كثر
واخيرا نترك محمد الاشعري يسال في واحده
من قصائده
ماذا افعل باليوم الذي وضع حقائبه على
ظهري واتكا الى حائط المبنى القديم ليبدا
البحث في شاشته الثقيله عن كائن مر من هنا
ماذا سافعل بالطرقات التي تمسك بيدي
وتقودني كطفل تائهن الى عش مهجور
[موسيقى]